my name is sh in this Ramadan I'm going to be sharing with you everything possible
that we can cover in these next 30 days on the subject matter of Dua it's
one of the most important subjects in Islam Allah subhana wa tala has literally linked Dua
and made it synonymous with worship the act of Dua which is supplication inside or outside
of prayer asking Allah for our needs is a subject that encapsulates so much about our
belief in Allah and our submission to him and the first thing we're going to talk
about are the three greatest misconceptions that people have on this subject of
Supplication now the first thing and you may know a lot of people who have this
misconception is they imagine that Dua is only for major things many people have this idea
that Dua is only for when you have cancer when you're about to die if you've
had a car accident and many people will not ever ever make Dua until something terrible
happens the companions of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam used to make Dua and ask Allah
for help even when they go to the market to buy sandals one night Prophet ibraim
who used to receive Revelation from Allah all the time he was eating his dinner late
he heard a voice saying oh ibraim why are you eating your dinner so late tonight
this is not your normal he said oh Allah I went from house to house to
try to sell something to borrow money to borrow food and I couldn't find anyone to
interact with or to trade with until late at night so Allah T responded to him
and he said is this what a friend does with a friend a because KH means
someone very close to you ibraim you don't ask me what kind of KH am I
to you and you to me when you're hungry and you ever asked me so Prophet
ibraim said oh Allah should I ask you even for my dinner Allah T responded to
him oh ibraim my if you need some salt ask me so Allah T is telling
us that Dua is for every little need that you have and you shouldn't imagine that
Dua is only for major things even a prick you touch the thorn and you want
that pain to go away that's a dire need so a dire need in the field
and the context of Supplication and prayer to Allah the bar is very low unlike the
dire need in Islamic law which is life and death so when you hear about supplicating
to Allah when you're in a state of dire need don't imagine it's the dire need
of the Sacred law which is the dire need that makes Haram life and death or
life and limb as they say sometimes that I could lose a limb I could go
blind or I could lose my arm or I can go to jail but in this
realm of Dua it's much lower than that furthermore dire need is anything that you want
not just need many people also Imagine Dua is only for like negative causes I have
a sickness I had a car crash I have poverty rather than for positive causes that
I want to add something to my life I want to make something better these are
also classified as needs because you want them your heart is unsettled without them in conclusion
Dua is not just for major needs Dua should not only be at the side of
a hospital bed or at a funeral Dua is for every big and every small negative
or positive if you like the video that you just watched subscribe to our YouTube channel
click the bell for notifications and if you really liked what you just saw support us
at
patreon.com